Hey, this is Mark CEO and founder of
Tango June 1st, 2009.
That's when we made Tungle Me available.
And since then, it has grown
exponentially and a lot of people are
getting their own TungleMe page so that
people can easily schedule meetings with
them. Now, what we've done today is
we've put it on steroids. We call it
Tungle.me version 2.0. What does that
mean? Well, as everybody's getting their
pages, well, people say, "Well, how can
we get and schedule meetings with all of
us?" Well, today we're adding the
capability where people can start
superimposing their pages together,
create groups, and on top of that also
find each other through our global
directory and easily schedule meetings
with each other. So, let me show you how
that works a bit. Now, about a month
ago, we've allowed people to join our
global directory. And by the way, 85% of
our users have agreed to join our global
directory. So how does that work? Well,
you can go to our homepage and also
within the app, you can do that. So
let's say I'm looking for someone called
Jackie. So I do the quick search. It
goes through and finds everybody that
have opted in into our directory. So
let's say I wanted to meet with Jackie
here. I can see that she's there. I
click on her and boom, I get to her
page. Now, of course, she got to
customize it the way she wanted. She
wanted to make herself available for
meetings on Saturday. It's sync with her
calendar. So as she has stuff, it
probably takes it out. Now the other
thing that we've added is
now you want to start superimposing
people. If you know their pages, it's
easy. You just start adding their name
uh with a comma. If you don't know their
name, you can also add it by email
address. So Richard, for example,
tungle.com.
So boom, you do that. And what you see
here is a group page where you see the
availability the common availability for
all these three different people. You
can also do a search from our global
directory start adding names here. Uh
and then what you see is people that are
also Tungle users. You can pick on them
and what you'll see is the aggregate
availability of all these people. So
pretty powerful. Now let me show to you
what it looks like in Tungle itself. So,
I'll sign in into my account.
So, bear with me here. So, I'm signing
into my account and there I'll go to my
home view. And of course, because I'm
signed in, I see my calendar here, which
is synced with my uh Google calendar in
this case. And there I see all my
contacts that also have TungleMe uh
pages. Now, what we've added as a
capability, and this is really powerful,
is the ability to create your group. So,
you don't have to sort through all your
contacts each time you want to schedule
a meeting. So, let's say I wanted to
schedule a meeting with my board. I
created a group called board. And as I
click on that, I can now see that if I
wanted to schedule a meeting with my
four other board members, I can see that
we're all available for half an hour
next week, uh, this week or a few hours
next week. Now, what's interesting is
that he can be on Outlook, Danielle can
be on a Mac, everybody can be on
different systems in different companies
across different time zone. And boom, I
see when we're all available. So, that's
pretty powerful. But there's also a kick
to this be because I called this group
board, I can also share it with whoever
I want. And the way I do it is my
TungleMe page is tungle. Mark because I
named this group board. I can send
people to tungle. Memark
slashboard
and boom the aggregate availability of
all my board members. Now, of course, I
see my calendar here because I'm signed
in into my account, but assuming I
signed out, people cannot see other
people's calendar.
They can just see the time that
everybody is available.
So, that is pretty powerful stuff.
Tungle out me on steroid. We're really
excited for this launch. Let us know
what you think about it. Um, and uh,
keep on tungling. Have a great day.